so
amd launched their really disappointing
rx 6500 xt last week and today is when i
can actually talk about nvidia's
response well it's sort of a response
but not really okay i'm getting ahead of
myself here i'm talking about this
little guy the rtx 3050 and it's
actually an interesting addition to
their lineup since at 250 u.s it slots
into a price point that hasn't really
been occupied since back in 2019. i'm
talking about the 16 series of gpus so
what are you getting here and is the
premium over the rx 6500 xt worth it
well you get a pretty cut down ampere
ga106 core and unlike the 6500xt which
has a measly four gigabytes of memory
you get eight gigabytes of gddr6 on a
128 bit memory bus oh and it has all of
nvidia's encoding and decoding
capabilities along with the full 16 pcie
lanes so no bottlenecking won't be a
problem on an older system right amd and
honestly i hate that i even have to
specify that it has these features that
were basically a given last generation i
mean come on amd anyways in terms of
mining yes nvidia did make this an lhr
gpu and apparently it sucks at mining
you can check out my video right up here
so it has all the things that we would
expect on any basic gpu but what about
the performance well that's what we're
going to find out right after a message
from our sponsor oh a 30 millimeter
frame so it's a little thicker ideal for
multiple locations but is the
performance mind blowing
exactly introducing the new t30 fans
from fantax the ultimate fan for
radiators heatsinks and cases where you
need powerful airflow with an excellent
sound profile
the three rpm mode switch is a clever
integration you gotta appreciate daisy
chain potential and of course a good
looking fan will keep the system clean
check out the t30 fan down below
let's get into efficiency and we really
see the ampere architecture at work here
it has a rated board power of around 130
watts which is definitely higher than
the previous generation of 50 class gpus
like the gtx 1050 or gtx 1650 but it's
nothing to be worried about the only
hiccup in my opinion is that since it's
over 75 watts we will not see an option
without external power connectors like
we had with previous 50 class gpus these
were great for pre-built upgrades you
just didn't need a six or eight pin
power connector moving on we have
availability and i know we've gone
through this before but i actually think
that over the long run at least this one
has the best chance of being available
to actually buy versus the rest of the
3000 series hear me out based on the
steam hardware charts rtx 3000 cards are
getting out there meanwhile you'd need
to scroll all the way down to the bottom
and i mean way way down to find one of
the new amd cards like the rx 6700
series but the question is whether or
not this thing is actually worth buying
even if you can find it i mean the rx
6500 xt is a good 50 less on paper and i
still wouldn't touch it for 1.99 let
alone some of the insane prices some
board partners ended up charging i mean
it's still available for a reason to
find out where it stands i lined it up
against a few cards including the rtx
3060 for reference then we have the gtx
1660 that launched for 219 way back in
early 2019 and the gtx 1660 super which
was 229 and launched in late 2019.
there's also the gtx 1650 since
technically that is the last 50 series
card that launched into the desktop
space it was way way cheaper though at
just 150 us as for the comparison with
the red team we got the amd rx 6600 and
the 6500 xt the first stop for
performance is one of the most critical
and no it isn't gaming look today most
people rely on their gpus to accelerate
everything from video decoding to
rendering these things are becoming more
and more multifunctional which is why i
came down so hard on the rx 6500xt last
week it's a one-trick pony that still
costs 200 bucks or more so what about
the rtx 3050 well i really can't
complain here since it comes equipped
with nvidia's full suite of encode and
decode features called nvenk that means
native hardware acceleration for renders
and nles like premiere and resolve and
it's great at it it even manages to
actually beat the rx 6600 clean one
thing that did surprise me is how strong
the gtx 1660 super is when it comes to
those same tasks if i had to guess it
might have something to do with the uh
192-bit memory bus because its nv
encoder is a generation older than the
ones on the rtx 3000 series card raw gp
gpu rendering is another highlight for
the nvidia cards since cuda tends to
offer better throughput than opencl but
and this is important to be perfectly
transparent we're using blender 2.93
here and the new 3.0 version has some
huge updates for gpu performance not
only does it offer better support for
nvidia optics rendering but they've also
included heterogeneous computing
interface for portability or hip and
that'll offer improvements for amd based
gpus too so yeah all of this just to say
that our team is already working on a
brand new test render based on the 3.0
version of blender it'll be rolled out
on our future gpu reviews so far the rtx
3050 isn't looking all that bad but at
the same time it almost feels like
people who do some creative work on an
older gpu might actually want to keep
their eyes open for a gtx 1660 series
card mind blown yeah mine too moving on
to gaming and things are pretty
straightforward here because it's almost
a repeat of what we've been seeing for
the last few years in the lower end gpu
market the new cards struggle to be the
old ones that launched at similar price
ranges the rtx 3050 isn't anywhere near
as bad as some others have been that's
because it does actually give a good
boost over the vanilla gtx 1660 and also
beats the gtx 1660 super in every game
we came across sometimes by a lot too
and against the 6500 xt well it just
clobbers the amd card like a seal whoa i
don't think i should say that now sure
nvidia priced this thing a good 25
higher than the red team's offerings but
it offers upwards of 40 to 50 better
frame rates in every situation as a
matter of fact the rtx 3050 ends up
sitting right below the 330
rx 6600 that gap between the 3050 and
6500 xt widens at 1440p that's simply
because the amd card is bandwidth
limited where some games like doom won't
even run at our presets that's pretty
ironic when you consider that not too
long ago amd was pimping out their eight
gigabyte cards over nvidia's six
gigabyte gpus yeah way to go back on
your word amd anyways moving to this
resolution also allowed the rtx 3050 to
move a bit further ahead of the gtx
1660s but it also increased the gap
between it and the rtx 3060. oh and i
might as well mention the gtx 1650 here
because i'm sure some people that have
one might be eyeing the rtx 3050 so yes
upgrading from the 1650 will give you an
epic frame rate increase but there's a
higher entry price too all in all though
it's good to see that the performance of
this card holds up pretty well if you
ever decide to upgrade from 1080p to a
1440p display also yes i'm gonna bring
up ray tracing here because this is the
first nvidia rtx series gpu that
technically costs less than 300 bucks
but don't expect to just you know turn
on ray tracing and get miracle frame
rates here you'll need to turn on
technologies like dlss nvidia image
scaling or fsr if they are available to
get playable frame rates at 1080p with
these technologies you'll actually stand
a chance at getting pretty decent
performance in most cases remember those
upscaling technologies are your friend
if you want to get a taste of ray
tracing from an efficiency standpoint it
seems like nvidia is on a positive swing
too since the power to performance ratio
for the rtx 3050 is better than the gtx
1660 series but when you compare it to
the competition the rx 6600 offers
generally better frame rates right
across the board while chugging down
about the same amount of electricity so
there you have it guys and i've got to
say i'm on the fence about this one on
one hand it's really annoying to see the
goal post for so-called entry-level
desktop gpus move higher and further on
the pricing scale while at the same time
seeing performance pretty much stagnate
like you're forced into a pretty ugly
situation if you paid around 250 bucks
for a gpu a few generations ago
you might need to pony up 350 bucks or
more for a noticeable jump in
performance at least these are the
prices that we saw pre-launch i mean
we're already seeing 6500 xt's for 270
bucks on e-tailer websites and 350-plus
on ebay in the end the rtx 3050 isn't
mind-blowing but at least it's not as
much of an insult as the rx 6500 xt was
so yeah that wraps it up for today's
video leave a like if you liked it and
comment if you got more to say as usual
you can click right here to see the
latest video right here to subscribe to
uh hardware connects right here to uh
subscribe to boot sequence stay frosty
my dudes and i'll see you on the next
one take care
i really hope that this card
specifically gets into the hands of
people i'm not an nvidia fanboy in any
way but um on the lower end things like
dlss will definitely bring more value i
mean it's not just an upscaler it
actually sort of improves the image
quality which is sick